[Applause]
ah two beers please say word has it that
Mort Krim plays pool here is that true
he wouldn't happen to be here now would
he
[Music]
[Applause]
better luck next time Laredo class
dismissed
Rachel another double ginger ale with a
splash of cranberry juice
hi mr. Krim i'm sam duvet
I know who you are we're friends on
Facebook oh you you remember I saw your
Facebook friends well it wouldn't be a
very good friend if I didn't yeah Wow
well since we're friends I don't mind
telling you I never miss a shot of the
week if you're considered doing chump
with a day
well the suits would like me to do it
every hour but you know what makes it
special is the fact that it's once a
week it's anticipation
it's like flirting is sometimes more fun
than sex yeah Aikman sex though I like
soup to son but I just enjoy heating it
up first
Oh buy you a drink
yeah you sure can and food too yeah
bailed me yeah we can also order food
yeah I was having be able to separate
all of us
yeah